here among the mountains and mores of
northern Scotland is a bird that
embodies the best elements of the
greatest Raptors the golden eagle has a
beak that can rip flesh like a blade
it's powerful feet and dagger like
talons have the strength to crush the
skull of its victims yet the Golden
Eagle wage is an uncertain war for
survival against prey evolve to vanish
into the landscape
[Music]
in winter these Highlands are often
snow-covered
but the snow can come and go just in a
matter of days for the mountain hair
this can be treacherous molting their
colors to match the seasons this pair
melts into the white landscape they
freeze when the hungry Raptor passes
overhead
[Music]
but without the cover of snow they stand
out cruelly against the brown Hills the
Eagle singles one out
[Music]
if the hair turns uphill it could take
away the Raptors advantage the chance to
strike from above
[Music]
the hair that took the high road
survives the Eagle seems to be at the
pinnacle of Raptor evolution but by no
means is that a perch rather it means
keeping up with the eternal deaths
between predator and prey